let's head to Blackpool now where
Michael go the leveling up secretary is
holding a press conference he is
speaking at the British Irish Council
Summit which is as I said happening in
Blackpool and he's taking some questions
at the moment would be required at this
point if progress is to be made the
progressive signal last night and also
t-shirt
onville to dogs
um thank you very much uh the the
program of legislation in the House of
Commons is something that is above my
pay grade I'm not aware of any plans to
pause consideration of the protocol bill
I think it's in committee stage in the
House of Lords at the moment I should
say though that the discussions that uh
the Prime Minister had with all
colleagues here
um about the importance of finding uh a
safe landing Zone uh I think we're
conducted on a cordial and constructive
fashion and uh as the Northern Ireland
secretary said he is a glass half full
man so we remain optimistic about the
opportunities of reaching a resolution
yeah could I say on that I think the the
the the the the essential point is that
a window of opportunity has been created
um with the pausing of the elections
um and the engagement between the United
Kingdom government and the European
Union in respect of talks and and a
clear preference articulated both by the
UK prime minister and the European Union
leadership uh the preference for a
negotiated resolution of this
it's my
assessment that the wind of opportunity
now does exist the space now exists and
to resolve the outstanding issues
pertaining to the protocol by
negotiation and obviously that would
need momentum it will need substantive
engagement by the EU and UK government
to make that a reality but I must say it
was
I take away a positive perspective from
last evening's meeting with the Prime
Minister Rishi suneck I think we both
agreed and that we would
maintain together a focus on getting
this issue resolved in the context of
The Wider issues that challenge us all
in terms of the war in Ukraine the
energy price increases in the energy
issue and of course headwinds in the
global economy so that's the context and
I think the wind of opportunity exists
if I may ask
Google and you know Google
um
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you and uh he's just at the back
afternoon um t-shock to you first you've
talked about that window of opportunity
how big is the window though I mean are
you talking about before Christmas or is
the real deadline for getting stormed
back now the 25th anniversary of the
Good Friday agreement
um in terms of anglo-irish relations
Simon covney um your foreign affairs
minister previously said just a few
months ago that he couldn't remember
anglo-irish relations being so bad I
wonder how you would somehow sum them up
now and to you Minister Gove um
ministers from Stormont should be here
today I just wonder how long you think
it will be before they are back around
the table with others because as we know
if the dup isn't on board with a deal
then stormy won't be back
we could first of all say that I'm
reluctant to put a specific timeline on
this but there is a significant window
of opportunity and the timeline really
in both the Prime Minister and I were
very clear about this last evening as
soon as possible
the sooner we can
resolve this the sooner negotiations can
bring a resolution to this the better
because both of us want the institutions
back up and running as quickly as
possible in the secretary of state was
clear on that today as well that that is
the actual imperative
at one level in terms of the British
Irish Council here that we we regret the
fact that the first Minister and Deputy
Force Minister are not here so therefore
that is the the real pressure point is
to really get this issue resolved so we
can create a pathway for the restoration
of the institutions and the sooner the
better and it's possible I agree with
vice president safikovic that the it is
possible if we have a substantive
engagement with momentum to resolve
these issues and um in terms of you know
there was a saying in Ireland that a
week is a long time in politics well
months can be an eternity uh so I find
I'm basically saying is I think the
relationship
um certainly uh prime minister name both
governments has improved very
significantly and I think we're both of
a mind to to with our colleagues in the
European Union and to get this issue
resolved in a harmonious way and I think
the meeting
over these two days has again reinforced
the importance
of all of us working together on shared
challenges and shared issues so
therefore the need to really get this
issue resolved is important because we
have other bigger issues also
really significant economic challenges
coming our way we have the war in
Ukraine where we all have to work
together and and and continue our
solidarity with the people of Ukraine in
respect of the immoral aggression from
from the Russian authorities
um the the next British Irish council
meeting will be in Jersey
um in June or July I sincerely hope that
we have
um ministers from the Northern Ireland
executive there then the sooner the
better
yes
uh good afternoon oh sorry yes hi Tracy
McGee from UTV and ITV
um and Tisha can I ask you first of all
you were talking last night about there
needing to be made on the bones in terms
of the discussions between the
governments and I assume potentially the
offer that will be made from the UK
government to the EU
um
and also if there is a deal is there a
recognition from the Irish government
the EU and do you think the UK
government that any deal that is reached
will have to have unionism on board or
there's no chance of storming coming
back
and uh do you Minister gov a question uh
first of all if the government is going
to be forced into a new austerity given
what was announced today
um what impact could that have on
leveling up especially if that involves
real-term pay cuts for public sector
employees and also I can ask the
question
in Northern Ireland people are still
waiting on the 400 pound payment for
help for paying their bills what is the
UK government going to do to make sure
that the people the households Northern
Ireland are treated equally
I could just so quickly say that um
it really is a matter of
both the EU and the UK working out
mechanisms to resolve issues we've
always said that there are legitimate
issues that need to be dealt with
we've also said that there are other
sectors of the Northern Ireland economy
that have benefited in the current
situation with the protocol
manufacturing has been very clear to us
that
situation is good for them certainly
over the last two years also the food
industry the agri-food industry has been
very positive about the impact of the
protocol and everybody in Northern
Ireland has been unanimous in saying
they want to maintain access to the
European single market so those are the
clear starting points that's it on
consumer goods and other areas there are
issues have Arisen which I believe can
be resolved and it's not so much one
offering site offering the other it's
both sides coming together to sort of
explore and work out to a mutually
satisfaction satisfactory in a mutually
satisfactory way the issues and I was
struck by the prime minister's pragmatic
approach understanding where the
European Union are coming from but also
he then seeking obviously do you
understands where the United Kingdom is
coming from and that's always a good
basis to start negotiations and to get
involved in negotiations so that's why I
remember hopefully I do not understate
the difficulties I do not understand the
challenges we have to keep all parties
on board
within Northern Ireland and I maintain
regular dialogue with both unionist
parties as well as all of the other
parties so all of their inputs are
valued and are very important and we've
always acknowledged legitimate concerns
of unionism in respect of
um of the protocol one addition I would
say is it's also important that the
voice of industry and business is is is
um Herod in respect of the
practicalities of of of any solutions
because they have to operate them on a
day-to-day basis and they have good
insights to offer and have offered them
to Vice President Kennedy to the UK
government in respect to the legislation
that was tabled and it's going through
Iran it's exciting through the uh also
Lords now but which would be injurious
actually to some aspects of Northern
business and they were able to point out
to us the nuts and bolts of it so
I think that covers all your points